各位好 我是葛旭
那如何阅读这个老大男的问题
其实有方法解决
那么我们想通过几次很简短的课
和一系列的这个练习建议
跟各位把这个事情说清楚
把这个实操性很强的这样一种技能
教给大家
那第一课呢
就是我们想要
我第一课的名字叫做
你的阅读是作者的写作
那么就像考试一样
没有任何东西比你理解初题人的思路更加有效的备考了
所以如果我们要是理解一个作者头脑中的这样一幅图景
是如何转换成他最后的这样一种线性的文字
如果我们先把这件事探究好的话
我们理解了作者
那么我们会更容易的去完成阅读任务
如果用图示来表示
大体上作者在头脑中会出现这个样子
就是此类的这样一种结构
它要表述一种论述和观点
那么作者毕竟他要写书
写书就是那种长篇的那种论述
文字是一个线性的一维的东西
所以作者在去把立体逻辑给他展开的时候
其实它是一个结构的过程
就把立体的东西变成一维的
现行的这样一种文本
所以他经历了这样一个过程
到了我们做读者去读书的时候
其实我们就假想一种情况
如果某一个人
比如说卢梭
比如说弗里德曼
他能够跨越时空的
向你进行脑电直连的话
他想什么东西
立刻会硬到脑海中
我们就不用走黑色的那两个方块
那么麻烦的过程了
其实他直接就把头脑中的东西
转给你就可以了
但是呢不行
我们人类语言传输的这个方式
比较简单和落后
不是文字就是语音
每一个都是线性的
所以我们需要一个重构的过程
那其实接下来的
就是我们现在这一次课呢
重要的就是给大家重述一下
这个作者解构的这个过程
而读者重构这个过程呢
我们将会在下两次课
给各位去讲到
那么磨刀不误砍柴工
今天的这个课讲过之后
我们并不一定真的会能够把一个现行文本真的重塑起来
就是把重构这个立体的逻辑
但是我们至少知道作者他是怎么样写作出这样一个论述显强的文字的
所以我们本课的目标就是以托马斯索威尔
他的知识分子与社会中的一个节选
大家别慌很短
我只选了这么三四段
它为例
所以我们需要做两个任务
第一个就是
大家跟着我去还原一下
非文学类的文章
文学类文章
我们代入感是很强的
对吧
很多人很多同学
这一块并不是什么
特别难的一件事情
但是非文学类文章
尤其是指这种论述性质
我写一下的argument
论述性质的这种文章
它的作者组织文本的全过程
那么它的目的其实就是
我去给大家
帮着大家还原
那大家给各位的留下的任务
其实就是理解
理解这样一个感觉
文本是线性的
怎么个线性法呢
逻辑是立体
怎么个立体法呢
直观的感受是什么样子
那两者的关系又是什么样子
那这样的话
我们接下来
简单的让提醒
也是友情提示一下
在另外一个包
就是如何思考这个课程包里面
我们提出了三个点
一个就是概念
一个是命题
一个是论述
所以这一块如果大家学过的话
那么理解起来
我们今天这个课会更容易一些
当然你要是没有印象了
或者是没有学过的话
也没有关系
但是我两门课是互相促进的
大体上
我给各位简单的陈述一下
就是非学术类的
非文学类的
就是学术类的这种文本
它里面会提出各种各样很大的概念
各种各样的主义
什么各种各样的理论
那这些概念
你可以把它看成一个又一个的词
那一般来说
一个命题
就是这个东西是什么
或者这东西不是什么
它是一种陈述
比如说我们所说的这个主题
每一个文章的主旨大义
这就是一个大命题
那么你会发现一个大命题
它需要有很多很多的小命题
去作为一个支撑
比如说世界上所有的苹果都是红色的
你看这就是一个大命题
它可能为真可能为假
对吧
你怎么来去论证它呢
比如说我们家的苹果就全是红的
你看这是一个小命题
对吧
它也可能为真也可能为假
那它至于能不能支撑世界上所有的命题
苹果是红的这种命题
那就是另说了
但大家注意它支撑的这个过程
这两者之间的关系
这个黑色的线
我们管它叫做论证
所以一个所谓的论述
一个所谓的议论文
一个所谓的argument
实际上就是这种概念
由命题
就是概念这种一个一个的词
然后用命题来表述它们
去陈述它们
让你去判定
那么如果你判定不了
他就给你叠加各种各样的命题
去论证他最核心的那个大的命题
好吧
这就是一个简单的一个回顾
那我们回到本课的这个目标
托马斯组尔节选
我再啰嗦一下
我带着大家去还原
各位去理解
本本和逻辑之间的这种关系
好吧
那我们的这个套路
就是今天我们走这样一条线
下一节课我们走这样一条线
那既然是写作思路
我们就简单的
为大家绘声绘色的描述一下
托马斯索维尔
他现在看着
大家看这张图
他头脑中形成了一个可恶的形象
就是很多经济学领域之外的知识分子
就是我们所说的公知
索维尔特别不喜欢这些
不懂经济学的知识分子
天天对经济学品头论足
所以他这样去想
他知道这些人
他就锁定了一个话题吧
叫做收入分配问题
那么他现在想批判一下
这些知识分子不懂收入分配问题
不懂呢
你叫虚心去问
对不对
但是呢
通完索格尔现在想
我想写
在书里面去讽刺一些这些人
那么他怎么去写呢
一方面
他要向读者说清楚
这些知识分子的理解
是什么样的
作为A选项
是吧
你看一下这帮知识分子是这么理解的
对某一个问题
没有分配问题
那么如果你要是懂经济学的话
他们是怎么理解
经济学家们是怎么理解
经济学专业的学生们是怎么理解的
或者在商业领域里
理由所成就的这一些人
从事经济建设也好
从事商业活动也好
这些人是怎么理解的
形成一些对比
然后他还想给读者们
去分析一些深层次的原因
就是这些人为什么不懂
如果这些事
你看直观的这种体现和深层次的原因
这两个放在一起
其实是一个很强的一种论述
我们不能说它是一个摧毁性的论述
对吧
就是你写的越多
那么你的可信性就越强
这样就能达到中间的这个目的
它的这个点
它想表达的这个意思
就是很多知识分子不懂收入分配的问题
言外之意
就是他未来将会去批判一下
就是把知识分很多不在这个领域里面的专家
他们的这种微信给砸毁
是这样一个目的
好了
我先刚才
刚给大家比较露骨的描述了一下
某经济学家
他是他的内心的一个活动过程
所以我们来还原一下
他怎么去写这个文章
这是一个立体的东西
它怎么变成线性的东西呢
那我们来看一下
首先上来它是这样写的
这个我就直接一段一段
给大家放在这个PPT上
第一段
我给标一下
这是第一段
它说啊
多数经济学领域之外的知识分子
对学习哪怕是最基本的经济学原理
都没什么兴趣
上来植入主题
就是说我先批评一下
我先批评一下
他其实这个既然是一本书嘛
买了他书的人
其实他写作起来不需要特别含蓄了
我直说主题了
我有整本书几百页
我来论书
为什么这些人实际上是无能为力的
他说
然而他们在面对一般经济问题
尤其是商业问题时
以及在面对许多围绕所谓收入分配的问题时
却会毫不有余的发表轻率的声明
所以他其实已经把一件事知识分子不懂
知识分子没什么兴趣
轻率收入分配这件事给说清楚了
然后他要会声会色的描述一下
他说那好
如果你不明白什么叫轻率的表明呢
声明呢
那么我给读者举一个例子
叫做例如
著名小说家约翰斯坦贝克
在评论为慈善事业大幅捐赠的许多美国富豪时
就曾这样说到
人们只记得住那些贪婪的金融家
他们三分之二的人生都在忙于从社会中攫取财富
只在余下的三分之一的人生当中才来回报社会
好
那你看
他写完这一段之后
在这个作者的头脑里
他这个逻辑链是什么样子的呢
我给各位去看一下
红色的部分其实就是把这个它主要的这个点
当然我们说一本书里面有比这个命题更重要的一个大命题
对吧
那我们看微观的这种情况
在这个短短的这几段里面
最重要的点他已经提出来了
叫做很多知识分子不懂收入分配的问题
那么托马斯·隋格尔写完之后
脑子里一定说这些知识分子理解是这个样子的
我举了一个例子
就是他说我举了一个例子
有可能他觉得举的例子不够
也有可能他觉得光举例子是不行的
你还要真的去说理
去把这个事说清楚
那么接下来呢
他的第二段他说
文字与逻辑的对应关
这个文字与逻辑的对应关系是什么样子
我们看一下
他说这样一幅生动的图景被
这是第二段
这样一幅生动的图景
被精巧的辞令创造出来
诸如卡内基 福特 洛格菲勒等人
从社会中大量攫取财富
我们看出来其实是跟上一段
他其实接着上一段写的
对不对
他说这个社会被这些人活动搞得越来越穷
然而斯坦贝克和其他大多数知识分子
却不去费任何周折
以证明他们三位以及其他企业家
是如何做到这一点的
所以大家就可以看上面这个部分
还是在去讲知识分子的这种理解
但实际上大家如果你是托马索维尔的话
其实你想写的
你想写的就是要反击了
对不对
我一定要写一块就告诉你懂经济学原理
实际上他们是怎么理解的
所以他继续写到
他说实际上这些企业家
却是通过降低他们自己产品的价格
使其低于竞争对手的价格
然后从显著增加的销量中获取了财富
更低的价格可以让更多普通人能够买得起这些产品
同时也提升了普通人的生活质量
并且使产品的销售商们通过显著增多的顾客而致富
那大家看索维尔心里面的这个想法
就是我啊
用最简单的语言
给你描述一些经济学原理
其实说白了就是一条
这个在自由交换里面
就是只要双方自愿的话
尤其是企业家和客户之间的关系
不是说我去压榨取你
对吧
企业家实际上
他真正敌人是另外一个企业家
对吧
但是索维尔写的这个话
让大多数人其实是
比如说我就很幸福
对不对
他们去挣钱是他们的事情
但是你想受了福利
就是你的事情
对吧
这两事你要分开看
你不能因为我挣到钱了
你就心里面酸
柠檬精
总而言之
创造财富正是一个过程
而不是通过使他人变穷
才使自己变富
所以他心里想
当然索格尔在写作的时候
他恨不得
把上面的这个如何这两个字
加重
你看如果我要念出来这个东西
和他写出来的东西是不一样的
这传递的信息也是不一样的
我要念的话
我会说斯坦贝克和其他大多数知识分子
却不去费任何周折
以证明他们三位以及其他企业家
是如何做到这一点
就是如何赚取了大量的财富的
实际上这一暗喊了就告诉你
没有搞得越来越穷
当然我们的目的并不是说分析这个文本
它写得有多么精妙
我们只说索维尔脑子里有这样一个框架
我们从刚才看出来的时候
它确实是要往这个方向写
懂经济学原理的人的这种理解
所以我们把这个文字与逻辑的这种对应关系
给各位去展示一下
就刚才这一段
你看
知识分子的理解
在这儿
那实际上懂经济学原理的人的理解在哪呢
在这个位置
在黄色的这个位置
对吧
所以
所以写完了之后
他就想
如果
其实他就想
我现在就开始算了
比如他有100个读者
现在应该有50个被说服了
或者60个被说服了
或者有一些人的可能
还是抱着一种质疑的心态
说你肯定你还是这个交往过正了吧
对不对
你还是这个有一点over generalize
这个过度概括了
对不对
那我们来看一下
他接下来又写了一段
他说无论如何
市场过程的负面形象
已经招致了知识分子的此类提法
如掠夺大亨
经济保皇派等
但知识分子中并没有人去回答
以下这些显而易见的问题
你看这个索尔脑子里面肯定想的是
我如果把这个命题再提升到一个高度
我再去证明它的话
我应该去追溯一下你的原因
对吧
我光从表面上给你展示知识分子
和懂经济原理的理解是不够的
我还是要展示一下
为什么这些知识分子会这样去理解
这是他头脑中想的事情
所以他说
原因呢
就是不懂的原因很简单
就是他脑子想
那我怎么去说这个话呢
他要这样说
没有人去回答这样一个问题
当掠夺大亨降低自己产品的价格时
他们掠夺的是谁
这个基本上就是直接抨击
就是这些人不懂的原因是什么
这些人不懂的原因
就是这些知识分子
压根就没有去往戏的方面去想
对吧
你仔细想
这些夫人们
他掠夺谁了呢
他把产品价格降低了
好像是福利别人
对不对
掠夺谁了呢
或者赚取财富
怎么能够像王室继承财富或权力那样
经常开始于闲境和谦逊的场景之中
是这样一个问题
实际上各种企业经常会开始于穷困不堪的情况
所以这个也是说知识分子
其实如果是我是索维尔的话
我可能会写知识分子根本不懂这些富人的艰辛
是吧
我可能会写的无聊一些
但索维尔的写法就是说
这些知识分子根本就没有问出来这个问题
他们压根就没想过这些问题
那么实际上
他们其实一开始都是
企业家们都是穷困不堪的
这里的重点并非知识分子
对这些问题的回答充分还是不充分
因为在大多数情形中
这些问题根本就没有被提出
更不用说回答了
所以最后这一期出现在这
就告诉你知识分子太懒了
都就是连这个问题都懒得问
或者是懒得想这些关键的点
懒得往细了想
那你怎么能够轻率的去发表这个言论呢
对不对
社会中的财富被掠夺大亨们攫取的这幅图景
事实上被当作了替代品
他既替代了相关事实
又替代了相关问题
所以他在写作的时候
那就一定是极尽讽刺之能
然后去把每一句话都像一个重锤一样
砸向读者的心里面
那么最终这一段和逻辑的对应关系
其实就是整体在去说
尤其是像他已经告诉你说重点
其实就是这些人为什么不懂这些收入分配问题
对吧
所以我想通过这个简单的这样一个例子
因为它只有四段
给各位说清楚这样一件事
你看
如果刚才我们把这立体的文本
线性的文本和立体的逻辑给它分成两张图的话
其实这样的
在作者的头脑中
是这样的
但是作者写出来的
是右侧这个位置
而到了我们读者这
问题就在于那么多的字
我甚至连右侧的这一点
其实都做不到
这就是为什么很多书
包括你看我们讲话的时候
其实也是一样的
只要是输出
无论是文字的还是语音
其实都是一个原理
我们头脑中呢会有一幅图
我们的这个
在往外去输出的时候
你无非就是把这个图音文字写出来
或者是用什么呀
用语言说出来而已
那你最后无论是写出来
说出来
它都是一条直线这样下去的
对不对
你得先说这个后说内
你不可能同时说两方面
对吧
各表一支
这是不太可能的
所以呢
这就因为存任何的表达和输出
或者是有效的表达和输出
一个好的写作者和一个好的演说者
他都要经历这个过程
那么其实他能不能真正把它表述出来的东西
或者他脑子里想法传递给听众或读者的话
其实他只能
这个作者和演说者
他只能做到一半
也就是他做到最好
也只能完成这个过程的一半
就是输出的这个过程
就是我们刚才说的
这个作者解构的这个过程
上面的那个部分
那读者重构呢
其实是需要读者去多努力的
这就解释了为什么有一些人
他根本不屑于给相应的读者去写书
对吧
比如说学术专注的
比如哈耶克去写一本书
米塞斯去写一本书
他不屑于这些普通的
没有受过经济学教育的
或者没有受过高等教育的这些人
他也不期待这些人会去读他的书
因为这重建起来怎么了
太难了
这个信息稳稳重建起来立体结构太难了
需要大量的额外的这种知识
大量的这个频繁的熟练使用的这种批判性思维的这种技巧
这就是为什么我们去读书的时候会有一个说法
叫做分级阅读
就是你的理解能力在某一个级别
你就去读哪一本书
当然我说的这个东西也没有任何歧视的意思
那我们不仅在普遍意义上存在这种分析阅读
其实隔行如隔山
你让一个学历史的人去读一个量子物理
其实它也是变成了一个幼儿园一样的阅读水平
对吧
那么我们为什么要去强调这件事
我们说了这个线性文本和立体逻辑
为什么它这么重要
为什么我要放到第一课去讲它
是这样的
大家可以看到右侧的这线性文本
如果你要想对这种这个人说的什么话
想提出一些批判呢
或者想提出一个认可呀
或者去抓取这些重点啊
其实并不容易
你必须要经历左侧的这个逻辑
这个架构
你才能够找到他潜在的这种疏漏
对吧
而作者在去写作的时候
也是这样去想
他只有头脑中感到很清楚
他才有可能去扩展他的这种说法
比如说刚才啊
那简简单单的四段
不一定就真的能证明很多知识
分子不懂收入分配问题
或者他们的理解是错的
他仅仅是提供了这几个部分去强化
就是紫色黄色黑色的部分
只会强化红色的这个观点
那如果他面临着各种各样的挑战
比如说学术里面相对比较杠的这种人的话
那么他可能会予以一个回应
那么在这个回应中你需要流出
你需要搞清楚
别人对你的攻击是在什么位置
别人对你的反驳是在什么
是在逻辑图谱中的哪一个部分
所以你才能针对他的这种反驳
提出你的反驳
这样的话就加上了灰色的部分
加上灰色的部分
有可能是扩展式的论证
对吧
就是我再开一摊
我再把这个事情给扩大化
或者深入论证
说我们就揪住一个点
比如说这些知识分子理解
你认为不同意的话
那我们再掰扯掰扯
对不对
我们再掰扯点别的东西
深层次的东西
之前讽刺过那些人
他们这深层次的这种理解
那如果他一旦在他头脑中认为
有必要加上灰色的这些部分的话
那么他的文本也就相应的去扩大
你看灰色的这个部分
但有人写着写着
可能就写丢了
他就写跑题了
但如果你头脑中有一个非常完整的一个框架
非常有逻辑这样一个框架的话
其实你会发现这种一一对应的这种关系
还是能够做到的
就是随时随地能够检查自己的写作
能不能符合很严谨的这种逻辑
所以这对写作者来说很重要
反过来你这个读者
对读者来说可能是一个比较遭殃的事情
就是他的预读量一下就增加了
比如说很多我们说各个领域里面
尤其是人文社科领域里面
经典的著作曾经都是一篇短短的论文
比如说这个哈耶克的
整个这种思想
其实都是一篇
关于价格的这个论文
亨廷顿的这个文明冲突论
那本巨著实际上
曾经也是一个
二十多页的一篇论文
很多很多都是这个样子
都是通过不断的
有一个简单的框架
然后在这个学术界里面
读者和作者之间的这种
交锋互动和反馈中
不断的把这本书越变
越长
那么对读者的挑战
也就越来越大
好
那为了能够说明这一点
就灰色的部分到底是什么样子的
我给大家举一个例子
就是刚才举的那三段里面
它后面一段其实就发挥了这样一个作用
就是在书里面
你经常会发现作者会去往前去补充什么什么点
或者是强化某一个点
那这篇文章里面的第四段
他就说
这并不是说在商业活动中从未有人做过任何措施
你比如说这个局势就是一个补充
他就告诉你
不是说所有的商人都是圣人
对吧
都是圣洁的人
如何如何的
而且他在这里面还提出了关键的一段
就是说在知识分子对市场过程的许多批判中
暗含之一假设市场过程是什么
是零和游戏
其中有些人收获
必然意味着另一些人的损失
所以你会发现
如果不论是作者还是读者
其实都能够立刻意识到
尤其是作者
立刻意识到
我觉得这些知识分子的这种理解
用个例无法去解释
无法有效的去说服读者
相信很多知识分子不懂收入分配的问题
所以我要把这个话说的更明白一些
所以我后面要追加一个段落
上面写着
我们其实就是说我们怎么去定义这些人
我们就直接用一个吓死你的一个词
零和游戏
什么叫零和游戏
我赢你输
要不然你赢我输
这叫零和游戏
那他的反义词是什么呢
比如说共赢
对吧
共赢win-win situation
就是我赢你也赢
这样的话咱俩大家好才是真的好
这个就是他一步点出了这一点
实际上你看
无论就是把整个知识分子不懂的原因
和他实际的这种理解上升到了一个理论高度
对吧
最后再补一刀
说这预设很少被知识分子清晰的阐释出来
但若不存在这个零和过程的预设
就是如果我们假设知识分子
不认为经济收入分配问题
是一个零合游戏的话
那知识分子
他就根本不可能去讨论什么
讨论其他的东西了
就不可能去批判这些富人了
对不对
这是无从谈起了
所以回到原点
我就说用简单的一句话说明
知识分子
你现在批判这个富人
我推了半天
只有一个可能
就是你会把富人和穷人
或者贫富差距扩大
或者是企业赚取利润
这件事情想成灵魂游戏了
那没别的解释了
要不然你怎么可能批判他们呢
对吧
所以这个就是
当然我们在这层课里面
无意对索维尔他的观点
有什么样的评价
我们只是给各位去完整的还原一下
就是文字和逻辑
就是他的逻辑是如何一步一步
这样转成文字的
我们用了四个小段落
所以这一节课我们完成的关键性的任务
就是把我们最开始的这张图
作者头脑中这个结构的过程
给大家还原了一下
但我们下一节课实际上就是关键的一项
就是实操性会更强的这样一项
就是读者那怎么去重构它呢
我们都知道你把一个东西拆了很容易
但你把它重新组装起来
显然是需要一定的技术
一定的技巧
一定的能力的
一定的训练的
对吧
我们下一节课见